citizens of the reject Nation it is time
Greg where are you going to end up today
what what is your final destination I
can't believe I did not see that code
you said what is what I was like what
are my plans today no you get us like
what's your final yeah yeah no I got it
that's hilarious that's good comedy I
see how you've made it so far in this
profession yes it is always good when
you have to explain your jokes uh we're
watching Final Destination which is a
whole franchise in which I've invoided
the entire thing I know the general
concept uh but I haven't seen the
franchise I don't know the general
concept perfect I I assume we have to
get somewhere that is it's a road trip
movie and then you die everybody in life
does anyway uh and if you like that
concept then leave a like comment
subscribe hit that bell all that good
stuff let us know where your final
destination of the day is if you want to
see more become a patron you can see uh
the full-length Reaction watch along it
looks like you're reading off of a text
there Roxy no
I was no they can't tell you want to
know what it is I thought you know how
to pick up lines I only only full length
Reaction watch Along Watch The
full-length reaction
go to the full length Reaction watch
along what's going on their final
destination is the patreon yeah there
you go to see everything
okay whatever Greg you weren't ready for
this but I was and that's final okay
let's do it
[Music]
how old is this movie I think it's like
2000 2001. you told me there's like six
of these right I have no idea how many
there are there's definitely more than
four is this a horror movie no it's a
road trip comedy did you you haven't
watched another horror movie it was a
road trip comedy
[Music]
is just satire what you're looking at
right now I genuinely thought that this
one was not gonna be scary no no it's a
funny one
yes all my favorite comedies start in
the rain
Tevin Subway did you know he was in this
I that's the one thing I said I knew oh
I thought she was like maybe in perch
I know is awa's photo on the cover
Sean Williams Scots in this he's not
even like single build
this music is unbelievably intense oh
it's just to set up the tension and
release for when the laughs come you
know
I think it's mean what you've done to me
Todd and George's dad just called
picking you up at 3 30 tomorrow and the
bus leaves the high school for the
airport around five
you gotta leave that on he is Young hey
man the last flight without the plane
crash or anything so I figured it's got
to be on the bag or at least with the
bag this has to be 90s yeah man he's
unrecognizable
I'm still here
[Laughter]
it's a comedy
senior trip with your friends in Paris
10 days in the springtime live it up
Alex you got you got a whole life ahead
of you
wow what an existential crisis look the
guy had they were in two different
movies just now one of them live it up
Alex
[Music]
180 A.M
this movie is about to do a 180.
[Music]
does that mean go down now look this is
for Buffy all right have a great time
twenty dollars for you guys to enjoy
they all have like a voice that is like
wow well the old time pictures
the talking we're gonna go to our final
destination say
for you if you harass my students damn
that's the teacher holy crap because she
looks young and hot
yes
uh yeah have you received any packages
from Persons Unknown to you
Final Destination September 25 9 25.
your birthday is the same as your
departure time
it's a omen or something
deep
yeah bro bro dude oh
my God what that teacher condones
inappropriate behavior now let's say
halfway through the flight your body
wants an airplane food out yes like
directly after he walks in
Crystal or Blake do you want them to
associate you with that watery sting in
their eye that reflexive dag at the back
of their throat that's how you talk with
your girlfriends yep
oh my God they're taking a dump together
is this what you do with your guy that's
how koi and I prep before a Comic-Con
panel me that's why he was late that's
right so I was like dude you're taking
way too long
[Music]
this guy is sensing all kinds of the
most alarming works
[Music]
he's starting to piss me off I know
sometimes I'm like I think you're
reading too much into things he
manifested whatever is about to come
this group of personalities and what
they talk about are so weird he's in the
25th row birthday is the 25th of
September 9 25 picking up on something
Greg could you trade seats with Blake so
she and I could sit together she asked
Tom but he said yes he had some sort of
medical
yeah
pushover I would have done the same
thing don't leave the 25th row you're
gonna cause a accident I guess because
of you I gotta sit here and watch
Stuart Little I feel like these are all
setting up some type of domino effect
that I have no idea where it's going I
think it's just showing us everything's
going wrong oh maybe this is like
Groundhog Day we're gonna have to relive
it no him getting on the plane I don't
know like all the steps
[Music]
we're going into the Thunder
we're okay
[Applause]
Jesus
it's kind of scary actually
everybody
maybe this is not the concept I thought
it was
oh
holy balls the guy was right
oh my God what is happening
[Music]
holy
could you trade seats with Blake so she
and I could sit together ah okay I know
you don't know but okay I think it is
concept I thought it was
you'll see I'll stop saying stuff is it
like Groundhog Day no
this is not a joke we'll remove you from
this aircraft
myself
I'm gonna kick your ass man
no one gets back on board that's my call
is it wrong that if I was this
embarrassed by what I just caused I
would want to be right about what's
going to happen
the left side blows up and then the
whole plane just explodes and it was so
real just like how everything happened
you know we've been on a lot of planes
that blew up
oh there you go watch it blow
my trip ready we're on that plane whoa
[Music]
that's what I would be like see I told
you guys not a good time for I told you
so
but man everyone would think it's my
fault then huh yeah yeah yeah but you
like planted a bomb or something
why are you still pissed you saved your
life homie
that's why
you take any sedatives before boarding
the plane or on board did you take any
sleeping pills any narcotics any
hallucinogens Alex you take any drugs I
saw it
big dump
Ling
it's trying to get laid my brother
George he told me to go and keep an eye
on Alex it's a great use of the clock he
stayed and
he told me to get off the plane but
remember Noah said I should get back on
but I I told him that he should go I'm
glad out of all the teachers she's the
one who got off why that's not like
looking at her same
[Laughter]
because I saw and I heard Alex believe
men
[Laughter]
the blonde girl goes off Brittany Murphy
energy yeah a little bit she looks so
familiar
oh no she's all alone
who would have thought a plane explosion
movie could be this fun do you think she
saw something too no I think she just
believed in based off his spiritual
energy or something like that he's not a
witch
so is this known as an action franchise
or it's an action comedy franchise no
okay
stop lying to me Greg action horror no
it's just a horror fridge worth the
action what action first you have you
seen so far explosion no it's just
horror and shoving
she made out with him that was a lot of
action 39 days have passed since we lost
our 39 loved ones friends and teachers
we got to have the funeral 39 days
before we can escape you did this
in time we must mourn and celebrate
theirs
with this Memorial oh I feel like that
was an important line
[Laughter]
it's fun it's like genuinely having fun
watching this I hope you don't think
brownie because my name ain't open this
wall but I owe you anything I want to
stay off the JD that Carter
yeah bro the what I control my life not
you JD
I'm never gonna die I'm never gonna die
you have a weird way of grieving homie
hey look when he gets over this thing
you and me we'll road trip to the city
yeah catch the Yanks get a hot dog it's
kind of like 80 years old
because of you I'm still alive thank you
they're both Outsiders now
Paparazzi that the hour of death cannot
be forecast or that death could arrive
this same afternoon and which has every
hour filled in advance death could come
for us at any moment that actually was
really affecting me until you spoke
I can't comment anymore like I was
hearing well live your life to the
fullest you heard that death is coming
what was your audition yeah what a shot
can you sit on this toilet for us please
I'm curious what's happening right now
I don't understand the brand name
it's
tofu
I don't know wow you've been consuming a
lot
just slide into her DMS man yeah
[Music]
wow you're off to a great shape it does
feel like he did that on perfect
what the hell
Flubber yeah is it gonna become a
monster no no no no no don't cut
yourself in your nose bruh
no no I feel like it's gonna go up and
down
oh he's gonna electrocute himself oh no
oh this movie's having fun
[Music]
superdell
yeah
okay
what does it say
Todd
[Music]
all right just don't panic man
it's called physical comedy Roxy
no ah that is your best bet do you think
he's gonna live through this or no no
you don't think what's his name's Gonna
Save him no bummer
[Music]
oh the water Retreats so what was the
water on the plane like what is the
through line I don't think the water is
the true yeah what is if I remember the
basic concept I I think they'll they
have to explain it at some point I'd
rather not give it away if I happen to
be right get out of here
why get out of here he clearly didn't do
anything they're gonna think you did
didn't you see it it caused Todd so much
guilt over George staying on the plane
why is she there
so something that elements like water
air the plane
it's a stretch
or is it really about the toilet
because you know
I think I remember water
oh yeah Todd's house last night
good question I'm glad you liked it they
haven't ruled out anything and the fact
that seven people got off the plane is
probably weird enough and it doesn't
help that the visionary's friend just
committed
no like you the sculpture doesn't even
know what or why it is it's reluctant to
take form and you're creating an
absolute but incomprehensible attraction
the production designer had fun with
that one
yeah
I didn't even know where those emotions
were coming from until you started
freaking out I didn't see what you saw I
I've never dealt with death before this
could all be in our head it just feels
like it's all around us what I thought
it was just the first of us yeah
obviously it's coming for each of you
whatever it was the man Todd it's
definitely gone
please you'll wake the dead Candyman I
just can't do that chemicals I'm
unbelievably confused got a very special
uh is that true what are all those tiny
marks cuticle lacerations when pulling
out the wire I wasn't trying to kill
himself it was an accident in death
there are no accidents
the airplanes that we ride or walk out
of it's all part of death's sadistic
design leading to the Grave
what a weirdo does that mean if you
figure out the design you can treat
death oh he's buying into this
conversation you've already done that by
walking off the plane your friends
departure shows that death has a new
design for all of you his eyes are
blinking you have to figure out how
Tony Todd's such a good actor and you
don't even wanna with that Mick Daddy
I'm sorry we broke in and no harm
no foul so do you get it
I'll see you soon
get it yeah it's death coming for them
yeah that was clear yeah so they have to
beat the design wait that was very clear
when then yeah it's not an elemental
thing but how is death moving the water
because it's death did you see how died
did it happen again
it didn't but I mean I mean as well have
this is a message or something or
someone hinting at a design right like
who the elements I mean you can find
Death Omens anywhere you want to
coffee starts with a c and ends with an
E so does the word choke so what we're
gonna choke today
this dude's like in tune with death oh
that was creepy I just realized what
happened he saw a bus he saw a bus
passing on the window but there was
actually no bus right
what if it still is our time if it is
then it's not finished and we will die
unless we find the patterns and cheat it
again that's what I'm wondering what's
the pattern so all that other stuff is
very clear to me yeah yeah
[Music]
oh no oh no oh no
why is this guy such a douchebag Carter
oh
looks like we have a bit of a reunion
here baby come on it is I need to tell
you okay New York's a really small City
not let this plane crash be the most
important thing in my life
I'm about to death plan
I'm moving on and if you want to waste
your life beating the out of Alex
stop walking stop walking yeah the bus
right
dude
brownie you set up this bus what a very
specific Vision to give him like let's
let him see it on the
oh
this guy Goosebumps
that's the pattern
you get it Roxy
I get it all
damn how could they figure that out
that's a really specific
thingamajig it's interesting that the
news showed that
first was Todd that was Terry died
anywhere they would have died hmm cool
gluten's next no I'm just looking at my
own front yard makes me feel nothing but
fear
this is about her loot 98 Shrek
he's gonna get himself in trouble I know
all things considered he has maintained
his composure very well through all this
a little too well
check on the internet
come on bro
lady you just signed your death warrant
yeah but I get it
see elements was there that's how death
travels I guess
there's this pattern
write a pattern
you sound like a serial killer right now
man mom's favorite
I don't play music nobody will be able
to hear you scream I like how they added
that little touch of what she said to
make us feel really bad for her for
what's about to happen there is a
pattern for you there's a design for
everyone and I don't know how yet but
I'm gonna break this one
I mean yeah you gotta like have some
consideration I like the frame rate
change I love the knives yeah I wonder
how she's gonna go too much on the knife
look at that frame rate change man that
looks Eerie as hell
subtle move with the bushes there
carbon monoxide poisoning
I think so no I think the knife
I can't believe I just worked with him
for weeks you worked with him Danny
Roebuck yes it was awesome he's very
talented
good
you gotta stop this stop this it's a
stupid mug you're out of here
soon you'll be gone
yes this will solve everything oh the
liquid come cometh elements
I really do like the way he the camera
captures a lot of the objects though
makes them feel bigger than they are
knives were a red herring oh there's big
knife too though
did you see that yeah
is that okay
see part of me thinks that it's got to
be something that they could still try
to blame Devon Sawa for thinking that he
did it death would try to frame Devin
Savile I think they it has been
[Music]
double shot
wooey
[Music]
morning uh the knife the decoy would the
knife just get involved it wasn't the
knife it was the glass from the thing
still sharp yeah it was telling us to
watch out for shards fire
cheese
stop arriving at the scene of the crime
knife now the knife oh no
oh my God
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't don't
oh God
no oh my God
you're a man
drop it and run good idea
oh
hey Alex
oh my God
when I was 10 my dad went into a
7-Eleven for cigarettes I guess that he
heard someone say don't turn around so
on reflex or thinking it was a friend
joking he did and a guy blew his head
off wow we've known she has no one she
married this he didn't really
want a kid so my mom didn't either
anymore that was
for my father and my family then death
yeah we're taking you to my dad's Cabin
in the Woods she's only a couple miles
from my house your dad Billy told the
FBI so you're running from her house I
was running because they blame me for
everything they blame me for Todd they
blame me for her they blame me for the
plane crash I mean it looks awfully
suspicious it was nice to see it tell me
I'm gonna get to see the Jets win the
Super Bowl
it's me Ray that's why you're not saying
I knew I should have up Tammy in
the pool that time what are you whining
about he said I'm next he didn't say
anything I mean he knows who's next say
it I said why bother I mean what's the
point right me and Terry we'll be back
together on the other side so why wait
any longer
elements not him
I can get nailed running this red light
you all gonna get right
[Applause]
wait what is someone gonna fly through
the window
put your hand back on the Wheel
[Music]
we're afraid to Carter but we're not
going to quit stop what you're doing
it's not this car how about the train
come on dammit Carter I want you to stop
this car right now
what a head
[Music]
I mean you guys can get out of the car
right
oh
it's not the way get out of the car come
on it's coming it ain't my time
you can just leave the car you can just
leave the car he's not gonna be able to
get out
oh wow
it feels like a trailer moment
[Applause]
whoa
it's cool looks like they really
destroyed that car
[Music]
wait who's next on the list
again
he's gonna die here yeah no he's screwed
is it gonna happen you're dead
yeah oh no just gonna get him oh
had clean off oh my God it was right at
the mouth I'm next
met me I can let it happen okay listen
to me all right hey get out of here
so now does he get to live or death's
gonna keep coming from because it
already skipped him so yeah yeah it was
so does it just keep rotating and going
around yeah
doomsday prepping it's funny how it
skipped like right away to Sean William
Scott and they've given him so much time
to prepare for this
I mean that seems like a really
dangerous thing yeah
you covered all the nails with corks but
then you put okay
flame on a wobbly pot
[Music]
is he the lead in all the final
destinations I have no idea I didn't
even realize it was Devin saw on the
poster honestly
[Music]
maybe don't put your head so close to
the knife
enough forever but I got this cabin
rigged to beat you now
where was so was that it for him no
because remember in the bathroom with
his Homie first it tried one way and
then it tried another way and same thing
with the knives situation but he beat
the thing the guy with the car it
skipped right away he saw that one he
didn't see this and he saw fire for her
and it was the fire I think it's gonna
be whatever he sees if he beats it I'm
not turning him in it's too dangerous
for him out there alone I go with you
you can't okay you just tell us where he
is wait at home I give him my word that
we will bring him in safely and
protective custody I don't believe you
[Music]
it's nice I never moved
just asked me to change seats but I
never moved I would have been up next to
Todd so he's not next he's not next I
never moved Chris he was in front of
mine yeah
get to her she's next
[Music]
so death didn't count on the Free Will
thing of him making a choice
going around
but what is your plan here it's trying
to get to clear yeah but how
on foot get over me that dog better not
die
damn death is really struggling here he
hasn't seen anything for her right I
guess not
[Music]
oh
whoa
I think the dog's fine
oh damn death is threatened by him
so death is coming from them both at the
same time now this feels like an
ambulance Entertainment movie no I think
death is just trying to stop him from
coming to hell
yeah
wow death you are sucking right now you
got all this at your disposal and you
can't stop her
there's some fun set pieces you don't
feel like this is an action movie it's a
little bit of an action movie there's
some fun set pieces
this is like twister now yes exactly
what I was thinking
oh
wow
how did he get there disaster
machinations Galore is The Cabin in the
Woods that close hey he was on a canoe
[Music]
get out of the car the staging to this
stuff is really wacky and wild
don't touch anything you're grounded by
the tires okay
kill it
[Music]
then help her get out but don't move I
Can Only Hold on for so long you know
what to do
when I do this it'll skip you and it'll
all be over it's the only way we can
keep that again is he gonna
grab the thingy I guess Alex get away
from there
I do like how you can feel the presence
of death growing frustrated yeah
super annoyed with them Alex Alex
everyone take turns giving him CPR let's
start with her mouth to mouth everyone
actually they don't do mouth to mouth
anymore
what culture man
Staying Alive is that what they do is
that the Rhythm yeah
staying alive that's how they teach you
now yeah they teach you staying alive
yes that's how you know how humor right
there yeah but that's how you remember
how fast
I guess she's gonna get on a plane
I can't believe it you know I just can't
believe it oh no way I'm saying but I
guess he was cleared of all criminal
charges there's a lot of question marks
about this and they got to their final
destination exactly it's a road trip
maybe he says you know how they talked
about in the other place did everybody
live or whatever maybe this is maybe
they all died and I don't know nobody
told me six months ago that three of us
would be sitting here having a drink I
don't know I mean sometimes it just
feels like the two of you are the only
ones you can really understand of course
they they are the two who can understand
who beat it you know we won
you realizing to be one Carter is a
chance at a full life
chance that I don't ever waste
that's why I went blonde
the at the explosion to turn the order
of our deaths right okay I was torn from
that power line by the explosion so so
why did it skip you instead of everyone
on flight 180 you me and Carter Were
Meant To Live
his death was so coming for you or you
could still be next
Carter I didn't make up the rules I mean
somebody's got to intervene before death
can skip them Alex proved that three
times it's been six months though
I
the safest
still next
uh-oh me
nowhere stay there okay
stay away
speak up
we want use your words
yeah that actually got me
this looks like such an expensive movie
nice look at all this intervening I told
you you were next
let's just get me oh no he is
[Laughter]
wait so then they would all die right
at some point it's Gonna Keep skipping
and skipping yeah
but they didn't all die now it goes back
to her
and then he has to intervene and then
she has to intervene and then he has to
intervene and then it then it doesn't
stop okay hip hop you don't stop is he
the is the next one the two of them the
uh Ali and Devin in case we decide to
watch it I think it's better we're going
not knowing oh my God I have no idea
you're such a purist I have no idea
yes I am what'd you think
I liked it I mean it's it's not flawless
I got some I got some things to
to talk about for sure that did not Jive
well with me really like what
well let's see let's see what happens I
thought the first half what do you mean
I thought the first half was more fun
than the last half which is kind of
weird because the last half goes bigger
normally I'm just so used to like
listening all these Pros before I go
into the cons that I had uh I mean yeah
like the characters were kind of
whatever I had a lot of question marks
about okay how did Devin get left off
when like no way the police bought all
the stuff about death or they're just
like hey we saw him try to save Claire's
life he's an all right guy he's an all
right guy one well they couldn't prove
that he did you know I think all signs
pointed that he murdered his teacher
yeah the teacher wanted us the confusing
one how he got off but yeah maybe
because the knife maybe the fire they
couldn't prove it because I don't know
you know they didn't have his
fingerprints because of the Flames like
I don't think he would have been allowed
to leave the country six months I think
they would have pretty much had some
type of trial going on that would have a
lot I mean it's it's you could call it a
nitpick but you know the cops being
involved are going to make me think
about the what the law might Implement
in a situation like this so there's that
and I thought the characters were um
kind of whatever I mean like I like
Devin sawwell I think he's a very
charismatic actor and I appreciated the
concept of the main character because
they still they still had an interesting
enough plot to allow our main character
to go on a journey so it's not just
watching only a plot unfold like it that
keeps it somewhat of a character focus
with him
um but some of his reactions to things
that I thought were so void of being
emotionally respondent to
friends and people he knows dying before
him yeah he like kept it pushing no
matter and it was like okay but your
bestie just died in the shower
strangulation style like yeah yeah so
stuff like that was a bit of a mising
ingredient but
um you know I'm sure there's other
things to sort of unpack but overall I
mean it's a little bit of a corny film
it's a little cheesy and the characters
are thinly written for the most part but
when they are doing the set pieces I
thought they were really fun it was it
was tense and okay how are they gonna
die and and it was creative because it
is like a dominant every one of them is
like a domino effect you know where
you're like what's what's gonna lead to
what and how how and the capturing of
them they get getting bigger and bigger
and I thought the shots of a lot of the
objects were really cool because they
would
it was almost like magnified every every
single object around us that way we were
paying close attention and everything
felt like a bigger threat for something
that felt so small so I thought that was
well done and the the ideas of a really
fun idea I think it's a fun idea so
that's my general General thoughts what
are your general thoughts I feel like in
order for this to work for me I needed
one very specific thing and that was
some kind of an explanation and they
gave it to me with the airplane seating
yeah like I was waiting for that moment
because like I said to you I was like so
what is the through line here I kept
wondering because I understood that
death they cheated death I got that
pretty quickly but then I was like is
this a monster movie like what's with
the water moving or why now they cheated
death so now why is this happening like
this and then when they explained like
based on the order of the seats and the
way that it would have gone I was like
oh that's really clever and I really
appreciate that they didn't just say
because it is the order you know like
that I thought that that was really
smart device that they used that I
didn't see coming in that kind of put
everything to me made everything come
together sure sure and was easy to track
and fun to track like okay so now I
still not 100 clear on the rules on on
the skippage slash like some of the if
you see it
but sometimes he didn't see it but
sometimes he did you know like where uh
the
um with several of the different people
he would see the way and then it didn't
go that way but then it kept coming for
them or like with Todd he just sees a
piece of paper that said Todd but he got
no sense of how it was going to happen
to Todd you know there was a variety of
the ways that it's coming to him but I
liked that because it kept it fresh and
we didn't know how it was going to come
to him so I kind of thought that was
really groovy like not to sound like a
screw me man I kind of did because I
didn't know what I was getting myself
into I didn't know there's a horror
movie if it was a thriller of sorts I I
don't know what I thought it was going
to be I guess maybe more like a
action
um
you said road trip and you laughed at it
at the beginning I thought maybe that's
what it was like how to get to the Final
Destination or something I don't know
how I completely missed what this whole
franchise was yeah the the concept that
I heard uh was that it's basically the
only thing I really heard was that
Survivor that people survived like the
concept of the movies are people survive
something and then death keeps coming
for them
so I was getting thrown off and they
were all dying on the plane I was like
oh maybe that's not what I remembered
what I what I heard uh but yeah no I
agree with your assessment there about
them having rules because they actually
out for the audience allows us to feel
like there's some semblance of Hope for
them defeating it for something that
they can't really see or tell when it's
really gonna come yeah the pattern
aspect it's like oh okay so now we're
doing something here yeah and allows
them to at least prepare or anticipate
in some capacity that corner scene
corner corner yeah yeah that's what I
said Cornell right yeah yeah am I saying
uh I I am not confident in its
pronunciation
Foreigner with Tony yeah exactly the
Candyman that was that he was so intense
and never came back
like I thought he was orchestrating
stuff at some point and he had the most
information too you get the most vital
piece of information yeah he's like
there's a pattern and I was like how's
homie know this and then we don't know
that but well I love Tony Todd's me too
me too
um and no one else could deliver that
kind of monologue wait did we see what
year this was that kind of like
tongue-in-cheek delivery like the
self-awareness it's 2000 there it is
yeah
yeah yeah exactly so it definitely still
had a 90s Vibe about it their lips are
all very red in the marketing I know I
mean they wanted to have that
I don't sex appeal yeah it's the uh
voluptuous voluptuous parts of their
lips you know
so I'm like oh I want to kiss all these
actors right now yeah and that worked
there was a good looking crew they did a
good job with this they really did I
liked the characters it was very
stereotypical you know with like we
don't know that he was a jock but like
the douchebag jock character with the
girlfriend who is like the cheerleader
type kind of thing then the punk girl
him being the outcast and then the kind
of dim-witted
um like goofier friend yeah I think it
could have used a little bit of
because it takes itself very serious and
but then again sometimes I wasn't sure
if it took itself very serious or if it
had an actual humor like a self-aware
humor about itself there are times I
couldn't tell yeah like what do they
think this is because there were times
where I was like oh this could make for
some really good self-aware like
situations because it seemed to have a
sense of awareness when they were like
teasing the audience of what's going to
happen to them what's going to happen to
them in each specific set piece uh but
the other times it was like no I feel
like this movie tastes so very serious
and it's come and that but I think
that's also lenses it's kind of like
this it's this train that keeps coming
in and out of directions because I was
like but sometimes that stuff that
self-seriousness made it more fun at
certain moments because of how serious
it was taking itself
um yeah and sometimes there's some
missing beats especially when the girl
got hit by the bus and it just cuts to
like he's at home and she's like I don't
want to talk to anyone and she's just
like out of a shower I'm like what was
the missing there's like I feel like
something must have transpired here that
was very important stuff left on The
Cutting Room floor maybe yeah yeah it
feels like it was trimmed down to keep
it that tight 90 minute Supernatural
Thriller and it was tight it was a very
tight you know it didn't drag it really
kept moving and we had a lot of
characters to get through a lot of
depths to have and they did keep that
pace up but I'm with you that there's a
some I think there would have I would
have felt more for Devin's character if
I saw him feeling for anybody or taking
any moments to grieve we also spent some
time with his parents or with people's
parents but then even his best friend's
parents that didn't come back into play
or anything like that and I think that
there were some emotional beats to be
had did you feel like after watching
this oh this could be a whole franchise
agree like oh I'm excited to see the
next one
yeah I mean I I don't I think the next
one I decided to see it for the set
pieces not necessarily like unpacking
lore or something like that but I
imagine that they probably get more
money per movie and they can go crazier
and bigger and more inventive and
wackier with the set pieces because
there is a bit of a wackiness to this
movie and I can only imagine that oh if
you get a sequel you get more money you
could even put crazier machinations
together of what weird Contraptions
death pulls together to take down these
teenagers I'm with you but then at the
same time you like the bigger the things
the less you were liking the movie
it was because the the character stuff
was becoming less interest at first I
was
that's what I mean by the the because it
was taking itself so serious but I
wasn't really enjoying what they were
doing with the like I thought the actors
were good
for the most part I thought the actors
were good and the
but because I wasn't in gay efforts
found the stuff about the characters
like so questionable
and a little bit corny that I wasn't as
invested in what was happening
but in the first half I was I was
actually like really into it I thought
they I think it was because the
potential for something really
interesting especially for the Devon
sawwall character was presented so early
on like something very gripping uh
instead of it just turning into a plot
mechanic where cops are chasing after
him and I'm the guy figuring it out like
this is something that could like drive
a guy and they would sometimes say it
you know like you're losing your mind
but I think they really could have
played more into that of
people turning on him going crazy and
that really working against him to the
point where he's trying to solve all
these things I thought the paranoia and
intensity of him could have like ramped
up and even the connection like his
deterioration or whatever it could have
been going further I don't really know
what direction I just I just thought
that they had so much potential for him
and then it became such a missing
element to me where he was not really he
would just be like kind of bummed if
someone died yeah I know what you mean
like the stakes they set it up so the
stakes were very high and it could have
been way higher had you know they
arrested him had him in a holding cell
and then somebody dies they realize it's
not him and then he has to get them on
his team and convince everybody whatever
it is there was different directions I
thought that it was going to go in as
well and I suppose that they could do
that in a sequel or the third one or the
fourth one I thought the story could
have just been more the story itself
could have been more intense instead of
just having like big elaborate set
pieces so yeah I mean overall I still
had fun with it and I want to see the
sequels I do I would like to see the
sequels and I and I think that they
probably just become more fun I think
the third one has something to do with a
roller coaster do you have any idea if
this is known as the best one
I have no clue I know people must like
the second one since they made like four
four or five or six there's like quite a
few I don't know how many there are and
didn't you just tell me that they're
making another one I saw a billboard for
it yeah
so I was like okay well I think it's
about time we knock this off our list
since we've had it on for months yeah I
missed this entire room yeah I really
missed the whole thing and you didn't
even know that Devin was in it no I
didn't even realize that was him on the
cover because I know old man older man
Devin Sawa from like the Chucky show you
called them old old man elderly man
senior citizen Devon Sawa this movie's
been out for 23 years he's a cut elderly
guy
he had a short have you seen Chucky
okay he's in Chucky he's great and he's
cut he's ripped all right you know him
do I know him yeah
personally yeah you're not friends with
him the way you talk about it makes it
sound like you have a friendship with
him oh it's very close
you're gonna need to listen to your
little kids no okay yeah have you seen
his body I call him Devi you call him
daddy I call him daddy yeah do you know
him have you seen his body normal
follow-up questions he did a good job in
this but I do think that his character
could have been a little bit stronger
with exactly the note that you gave
which is like
feeling
the loss and I didn't believe the
chemistry of between him and Lead chick
either
her and a ton of things too yeah uh
I'm trying to think of what it's not
Legally Blonde but something like that
did you recognize her
yeah I have no idea yeah
a billion things you guys at home will
let me know what it is and I'll be
kicking myself later it'll be another
Triple H situation still can't believe I
didn't pull that any other burning
thoughts no I mean I mean it's pretty
simple just to elaborating more on the
same I've been saying is that yeah
if it just had
if the characters not even that it needs
to have like a bunch of depth but if
they just had more a more personality to
the characters instead of just one notes
than I think that would have made me
care more about when they're gonna die
because I would find myself itching to
like
let's kill off someone else and I want
to get to another set piece where
someone dies I feel like I'd maybe dug
this more than you did probably it's
cool it's rare is it yeah I feel like I
dig almost everything I think I tend to
like things more than you generally when
we're done actually I don't know I think
I like things more than you no I I
really don't know but I thought that the
more I think this is one of those movies
the more you think about it the less it
really works so it's like I just gotta
kind of let myself I enjoyed it while I
watched it and I would say that too yeah
yeah okay well that's it that's our
final destination let us know if you
want us to have another final
destination yeah perhaps the Final
Destination two three four five six as
long as they go uh don't forget like
comment subscribe be a patron be a super
oh no no we already decided super sexy
Rejects
and I tell them all the things yeah okay
bye
foreign
[Music]